these aliens don't look like anything
that we've seen before
we are not alone in the universe
what is being visited upon our earth
[Music]
it's an incredibly ambitious show we're
going to see an alien presence we've
never seen before a biological entity
that we cannot even begin to understand
yes squad was lost in an encounter was
that your only encounter no
i just wanted our aliens to be unique we
found this shape and movement for these
creatures
that have an organic feel to them
as it moves through a space it will
tesseract
turn itself inside out
it's almost hypnotizing the way it moves
[Music]
they have this almost primal
sophisticated skin that doesn't look
like anything we've seen from an alien
before
it's made of ferrofluids so it can be
hard but when you touch it it moves like
mercury
if it's fired upon it would absorb the
bullets
they spell this sort of tarry substance
that changes over time and grows these
nano-organic structures
[Music]
we really did want to build up these
aliens as being this shadowy kind of
creature who showed us just how fragile
we are
the relatability of it makes it even
more scary because if they're not trying
to destroy our planet they're trying to
do something with our planet and that's
scarier because our home is under attack
we might be all it stands
between life as we know it
[Music]
and the end of all existence
[Music]
you